Hello, and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
This is the complete gate to Teleport, and
this is a workshop number two.
That means that for the next forty minutes,
roughly, we will be taking a look at
me,
work through a GitHub document as available to
everyone to work through in their own time
to show and share
some of the cool features of Teleport. Today,
we are focused specifically on application access. We'll
cover what that means as we work through
scenarios.
But first, I really just want to get
started, show you what we're working with today,
and get started with the first task.
These are live workshops. That means you're more
than welcome if you're watching us live to
put questions into the chat, say hello,
anything you want. Just reach out and we'll
do our best to get to that as
quickly as possible.
Now let's get my screen shared.
If this is your first workshop, you can
find all of these courses at github.com/rawcodeacademy/courses.
You will find a directory there called teleport
complete guide,
and this is six application access
because this is part six of the Teleport
course.
Let's
scroll down.
So I am,
for this workshop, and I I guess probably
for all future workshops, going to be using
the Acme slash less encrypt certificates with Teleport,
which means there are domains and DNS records
configured.
I have done my best at the top
of this README document just to tell you
what those are so that you can replicate
this in your own setup.
If you are calling us directly locally and
working through it in your own time, I
would encourage you to do a search and
replace for Rawkode.sh
replace it with a domain that you have
access to the DNS records for,
just to avoid any strange errors as you
continue.
I am using Linode for today's virtual machines.
So there is a Pulumi,
small Pulumi project available here in the directory.
So you can just run Pulumi up as
long as you've got the right credentials for
the node exported in your environment. And that's
it's gonna spin up a two node setup
with just Ubuntu 20.4.
Alright.
My DNS records are all created. I'm not
going to run through exercise one,
but I will confirm that they do exist
by running a dig t dot Rawkode
dot SH.
I have a wildcard configured, so I can,
and hopefully it can do anything.
We get the same IP address
and I set up for my worker
node
w one, which has a different IP address.
That looks exactly like I expect.
That means that when we install Teleport to
these machines, it's going to pull in the
ACME certificate.
Now all of these workshops are standalone, so
we're gonna kinda quickly fly through just the
creation aspect. And again, just to make sure
that everyone is comfortable with this and you
know what you're doing, it does not hurt
to run through the setup a couple more
times.
I'm gonna start with SSH ing to my
control plane node.
There we go. And we shouldn't have Teleport
here. This machine has only been spun up
around thirty minutes ago. There's nothing on it.
This is a very generic and boring Ubuntu
machine.
We're just gonna follow all the commands. So
the first thing I'm doing is I got
better with us in the first Teleport workshop
by not setting the host name. I expected
the node to do this
through the labeling.
If we take a look at the
automation here, we do add a label,
which seems to set it on the backend
for the Linode portal, but doesn't set the
host name of the machine in the SSH.
And then the host name, which is a
local host, and it looks really crap when
you start trying to explore Teleport for the
UI or for the CLI.
So we're fixing that today. The first thing
we do is set the host name that
we want it to be.
I'm gonna copy and paste all the boring
stuff. We're using
the
Teleport
Debian and Ubuntu package repository.
What confused
me and scared me
prior to jumping onto this livestream not recording
was that Teleport 8.0.0
has been released.
It seems to be pretty new,
but I don't think based on what I've
seen in the release notes, should run into
any problems today.
Fingers crossed.
Let's give that a second. The next thing
we wanna do is configure this.
So on the first workshop, we ran into
a little issue around the secure certificate. Now
I'm not gonna go into it in detail,
but what the problem was because I decided
just to record a tutorial,
which should drop
or be available by the time you watch
this. Fingers crossed.
And it's just because Teleport needs access to
the the root CA to be able to
trust those certificates
and they're shared. And most of my tests
were in containers or using Kubernetes where I
had volumes that shared those root certificates across
the different agents. But when I did the
workshop, I used Linode for the first time
and ran into some problems and that those
certificates weren't being shared across the different
VMs. Of course not.
We can just amend all of that and
use the public DNS records and real certificates
from Let's Encrypt. So what we do here
is we say Teleport configure,
which is just gonna tell Teleport to generate
base config. We did look at this in
the first workshop.
The parameters we can pass are just, hey,
let's enable Acme.
Here's the email address
for the account or the name that I
want associated with the certificates. Here's the name
that we rest to use and dash o
just tells it to save it to a
fail.
If we pop over here, we're not gonna
return on the last one, so let's just
do that quickly. And we are getting eight
point zero dot eight zero again. That wasn't
an accident.
No. Just a thing. And
we'll give that another moment. There we go.
And we should have access to Teleport
version,
which we do.
So we run this configure command and we
can see that it has created a config
at the location we expect.
And this is a pretty standard Teleport config.
We've seen this now a few times.
What's important here is that our proxy service
has the ACME
The YAML has the ACME key with enabled
to yes as an email address to attach
that certificate.
Alright. Well, I'm happy with that. I'm just
going to go ahead
and start
Teleport.
And if we jump back to our instructions,
that was the next thing.
We've got the example configuration,
which you should see.
And now we are going to
continue on from what we also done to
workshop one, which is your static token authentication.
This is not something I will encourage in
a production environment, but for these workshops, that
is a great way to get started quickly.
We will have a best practice video where
we talk about doing this in a nice,
safer fashion.
However,
what we want to do is grab this
token
and add it to here on the off
service.
It affects the indentation because that's all we
ever do.
And what we're seeing here is that we
want to have a bunch of tokens available
and the off service that allow
anyone with access to that token
to authenticate on a proxy and node basis.
I'm gonna add one more and fix my
fix my
readme
because we're gonna need it later and it
says we're doing it there.
Here. Oh, proxy node. I have fixed it
locally. Just haven't pushed it. There we go.
Even better. The proxy app and node. We
wanna allow the proxy service to connect and
speak to the Teleport cluster. We also want
to allow the app service to connect and
speak to this cluster and the node service
we want to allow to speak to this
cluster.
And the token is
Rawkode
dash workshop.
I see Russell has joined us. Hey, mate.
Russell is on the Discord. I've been talking
about my audio and camera problems
that have been affecting me for a week,
but today we're really bad. So I'm hoping
that I look and send all right. Feel
free to give me a thumbs up if
you don't mind. I'm gonna continue regardless.
And so we have our Rawkode workshop static
token available, and we're gonna need that when
we make, when we have other virtual machines,
nodes, bare metal, whatever connector to our cluster.
So let's save that and jump back over
to our README.
It should look something like this, which we
now have. Oh, let me see through here.
There we go.
And now we can create our admin user.
This is the user that we are going
to
use initially to set a few things up
within our cluster. One thing that's different from
workshop one is that we no longer have
access to roles equals admin with Teleport 8.0.0.
And it's now broken down into you have
to use editor and access.
The roles admin is gone. You can have
to record that, rerecord
that entire workshop, but that's probably for the
best anyway.
And we're gonna add logins routes so that
I can have route access to each of
the nodes within the Teleport cluster.
And we click our link,
we're going to sign up. Now I have
done some tests on this domain, so I'm
gonna reuse my password.
There we go.
Password. And I'm gonna have to rescan
and get my second
OTP
down here.
And that should allow me to sign up.
There we go.
Now, we have a zoom in. We'll see
that we have access to the Teleport UI.
We have one node listed here. Things are
looking good.
Okay. Now we wanna join the cluster.
We can SSH onto the worker node. So
I'm just gonna spot this terminal.
H l root worker one
Rawkode. Sh and
we'll copy these commands
like so. So we're setting the host name
again, adding the Ubuntu or Debian repository and
then installing the Teleport package.
Alright. Install.
I am providing the the config for this,
but essentially, we're Teleport that we want to
go and speak to this off server, which
is our control play node, t. Rawkode. Sh.
There's the off token that we added as
a static token.
We don't need the off service on any
of the worker.
Russell, audio is fine for me and I
can see the difference between your t shirt
and hoodie size of the light. That's good.
Awesome.
That's a win. It's rare that I'm getting
them these days.
Okay. So we've the auth service disabled. We
don't need that for things that are joined
on the cluster. Auth service runs on the
first node. And then we enable the SSH
service because we do wanna be able to
SSH onto any of these machines.
So I'm just gonna copy these two commands,
drop them in, and we should now have,
if we browse back to Teleport
and hit refresh.
Correct.
Alright. Debug in issue number one. So what
we expected to see there was on our
Teleport UI is that we would have the
Control Blade node and one worker node. We
didn't get that. It means it's potentially a
problem.
Saying
that is
not again.
There you go. Okay.
Alright. I'm not going to pay this this
time. So
this did not happen during my tests.
I'm just going to fix it later.
It was the VIM.
Secure.
Restart. Oh,
yeah. That changed the unit fail, so we
will need to demon
reload.
Start Teleport or restart. Sorry.
If we do a journal flu yeah. No.
Okay. So my my certificate my certificate
I think, actually, we're fine. What's happening here
is
let's say my joint token is not valid.
So let's see what we're dealing with.
See, it doesn't matter how much you test
this stuff, does it?
I think it's cool. That's incorrect.
That's perfect.
Rawkode workshop.
Okay. Let's see if we have any logs
here.
Cannot join the cluster with role proxy token
error
not found off go. Okay. So I've configured.
Uh-huh. Right. Okay. Gotcha.
Let's stop Teleport.
And
this is blow away the Teleport directory
and
gonna remove that and secure because
hoping we don't need it.
I think
I didn't restart
Teleport after adding my token, my static token.
So
Teleport,
Make sure our Teleport service is still running.
And let's try
this again.
There we go.
It has joined the cluster.
Perfect.
I I was nearly about to go down
a rabbit hole of debugging that I had
absolutely no need to go down. However,
restart Teleport after you change the configuration. That's
very important. Don't make that mistake.
Phew.
Alright.
Now we're gonna move on to exercise five.
We're gonna take a look at the debugging
application.
This is just something that Teleport provides so
that you can understand
how their proxy service works, how it's
modifying or mutating the HTTP requests. So you
can see the headers.
And it also does some really cool stuff
with JSON web tokens and certificates that allows
you to be able to consume
the credentials
being passed through the proxy service
within your application.
And one of those are really cool use
cases here is if you're using Teleport
with a GitHub authentication provider or any of
the SAML based authentication providers like Google,
AWS, Microsoft, etcetera, is that you can pull
in that user data and the rules
so that you can then use that and
pass it on to all of your internal
administration or backend
applications.
And we're gonna see if we can take
a look at that. Something I've done different
this time with the workshop is just provide
the solutions for each of the exercises.
So if you just want to copy and
paste the code, you can. But what we're
gonna do on this workshop is gonna try
and find the answers, which is gonna be
weird because I kinda know them, but we're
gonna go through the documentation. I you to
walk away from this knowing that the documentation
is there, how to consume it, and the
way that you would find these answers in
a real world situation.
So what I've said here is that Teleport
ships with a debug application that dumps some
environment variables for you to inspect, and we
want to enable this application.
We're just gonna go to a Teleport doc,
then to debug.
That's not the right one, is it? Dumper.
Yeah. That's something else. Maybe that's later.
I do dumper,
you know what? It doesn't matter.
My favorite page is reference.
Go here, click and config fail. Everything you
can turn on is commented and documented on
this file. So there's no It would appear,
and I haven't really searched for it previously,
but there's nothing under documentations about
this debug application.
But I do know that it's there, we
wanna play with it. So we go to
the reference, we go to the config, we
can search for debug,
if I could spell.
And what we see here, and I'll zoom
in, is the first hit, which is great
as that.
Boom.
If I highlight it, you can't actually read
the comment.
Teleport contains a small debug app that can
be used to make sure application access is
working correctly.
The app outputs JWTs
or JWTs, I believe we're supposed to pronounce
them.
So it can be useful when extending your
application. That means consuming the authentication and not
rebuilding it into your application when something that's
already doing it. So what we wanna do
is to enable this, is find the app
service and our Teleport configuration
and add a debug app equals true.
So
that's just my
system d log. We're gonna go to our
Teleport.YAML.
We'll go to the app service,
which we don't have. Alright. Okay. We need
to configure the app service.
So we can just come in here to
app service
enabled,
true.
And we know that we want debug app
equals true as well.
We can save that and I'm just gonna
cat it and we'll compare it to what
was in the documentation to make sure we
get what we expect.
App service enabled and debug app true.
App service enabled, yes, true, I think.
I believe both work. We're about to find
out.
And debug app. True.
What we can do now,
restart
Teleport.
Make sure that we have no errors by
popping into here. It doesn't look like we
have anything. If it fails to parse the
config, in fact, you get a pretty quick
warning about it. And in fact, why not
let us just break it?
Let's see. Enabled equals
fluffy kittens.
That doesn't break it. I'll be surprised, but
let's go for it.
Well, that's the YAML thing. Interpret that is
true, isn't
It's funny.
Yeah. Okay.
Let's leave that as true. Let's just add
a fake setting.
Sure.
Restart journal.
There we go.
Pails parsing the config
fail. YAML on marshall errors, lane 40 field
fit setting, not found in the type. So
on messing the weird YAML except in any
value as a true or trippy value,
you get really good feedback when Teleport is
not happy with your config.
So we'll just restart that.
What should happen now, in fact, do we
talk about it here,
is browse to the debug application. So we
believe we've enabled it. And the way that
we can confirm that is to come back
to the portal
and click on applications.
And you'll see that we now have access
to the dumper application.
So what I like about application access on
Teleport is that when we set the
app service
up
is that it uses wildcard DNS to actually
give resolvable
names to all of your applications. You can
see we can use dumper. T. Rawkode. Sh
actually just browse to this application.
So if I just did dumper.t.
You're seeing there was a whole bunch of
redirects there.
So what happens is when we go to
that webpage,
it's checking to see if we're logged into
Teleport, makes a few calls, gets the certificates,
approves them. And then when it's happy,
that should back out to the application that
you actually want to see. The Dumper application
here is just showing us the HTTP request
stuff. So we can see,
we have a GET request, we can see
the host.
And this is the proxy host. You know,
we do have the x forwarded for information
down here. So if you've worked with HAProxy
or NGINX in this configuration, you should be
relatively familiar with these headers or I guess
most of the buzzers as well.
We have accept stuff, which is pretty common.
We've got access
token here
and we've got our Teleport assertion here.
There is a whole bunch of stuff here.
Let's jump back over here.
So the last thing we want to do
here is just we want to decode this
token. Actually, I want to dissect and understand
what I have access to. No.
We haven't configured this Teleport with any
enterprise level authentication,
right, GitHub, Google, etcetera. So I'm not gonna
get a whole lot back out. You can
imagine how that would be consumed.
Next week, we do have a tutorial on
configuring Teleport. So in Teleport open source, you
get the GitHub authentication module for free. So
as long as you have a GitHub organization
with some teams, you can use that to
integrate and log in to your Teleport instance.
But for today, we're using local user. So
I'm gonna copy my Teleport JWT assertion,
which is just the same as the access
token up here for the record. We're gonna
go to jwt.io.
This is like the de facto say if
you're ever doing JWT stuff and you just
be able to debug why it's not working,
just go here because it has this thing
where you paste it in
and it will give you all the decoded
headers, payloads, and signatures. Now, if we know
the private key, we can drop it in
and it'll tell us whether this is synced
correctly or incorrectly.
Not really worried about that right now. What
I really
want to emphasize and show you is that
we have the expiration time, we have the
issuer, which is just our Teleport here, p.rawkode.sh,
and
we have the roles, the username, and the
subject is the same in Jotlin. So you'll
often see sub and username together
and the same value. But we can see
the roles. We can see I'm an editor
and I have access permission. These are the
roles that when I did the T control,
Teleport control, I don't know how to say
that,
users add, we said these are the roles
we want to help these users do.
The Teleport allows you to define your own
roles and throw in more metadata there. We
will have an episode, we'll have a workshop
and a deep dive into RBAC in a
couple of weeks time, but you can see
how we're getting this information. So
if you can validate the JWT
and the signature,
you can trust that the information you're getting
back in this JWT payload can be carried
and passed onto your application
and you can have
a really cool authentication model integrated with Teleport.
Sweet.
That was relatively
without hiccups.
Now, if you take a look at our
solution, that's exactly what we did. So on
the Teleport server, we modified the Teleport. Yaml
file. We added debug app true under app
service, which looked like this.
We restarted Teleport
and we are done.
So let's try and do something
little bit more interesting.
Let's install NGINX onto our Teleport server.
We'll add NGINX as an application to the
Teleport cluster.
We're then going to go in and modify
NGINX to only respond to requests on the
private IPv4 address for the server, or even
just onto 7001,
whatever, entirely up to you.
And what we should be able to do
is actually just confirm
the NGINX still works through the application access,
but will not work
through the nodes public IP address.
Cool.
So let's do an apt
install
NGINX.
If we browse,
we'll give this a couple of seconds to
finish first.
Ninety nine percent. Come on.
It's like a software developer project where my
teammates says it will take an hour.
Be clear.
I'm guilty of that too, actually.
There we go. So
now we installed NGINX on the
control
plane,
but we can't actually browse to it right
away because this is our Teleport server.
So what we're gonna have to do is
come into our NGINXconfiguration.conf,
find the server block.
Oh, it's gonna be in sites available perhaps.
Yeah. Okay.
Engine x, sites enabled, find default,
opt down.
And I'm just gonna modify this to run
on port eighty eighty
on 8,080.
I would suspect
NGINX hasn't started yet, so we don't have
any logs.
But
let's just do a restart
NGINX.
And hopefully now
we can do a t.Rawkode.s
h port 88.
No. HTTP.
That time something went wrong.
I think that's just been silly.
Let me grab the IP address of this
machine.
What was happening with the t. Rocket. Is
it?
Not important.
We have an NGINX page here.
So our
mission is to add NGINX as an application
to the Teleport cluster.
So we're gonna go to the documentation
and we're gonna try and work out how
to do that.
So we can click on application
access gates,
connect applications.
And if we pop down here, it's gonna
walk through some of the stuff that we've
already done for today, you know, adding tokens.
Now you can use short lived tokens for
the application
proxy process that you can run.
We're gonna configure it straight into the Teleport.
Yaml for now, we don't have to worry
about that.
If we come down to start an application
with a conflict now, because
this is a server process and we have
all of this stuff available, we've
already added app service ID bug true, is
that we could just grab this syntax here
for providing a list of applications to expose
from this machine
and modify it to suit our needs.
So we can modify our Teleport. Yaml.
We're have to do so much reinventing here.
So we've got apps.
Let's try and get rid of some of
the comments from there. I'm gonna remove anything
that's optional.
It's all optional. This is all you need.
So we need that to align. There we
go. So we say apps, we give it
a name.
I think it would be fair to call
this one NGINX,
which is available on this local machine
on port 8080.
So we can just use local as 8080
we save this.
You haven't seen it working yet, but being
able to expose things from the machine through
the config is really, really easy. Just needs
the name and then GRI and Teleport will
handle the rest.
We can do a system control,
restart,
Teleport.
And if we take a look at the
logs, we should see things are still happy.
We've got our Oh, I kinda missed it.
Where'd it go?
There we go.
This info lane here, apps first down as
sixty days. So we're now running an app
proxy server here.
And if we pop over to this
and hit refresh,
we now have our NGINX application here. You
can see the DNS name has been generated
for us, NGINX. T. Rawkode. S h,
and the labels.
These are added by Teleport to seeing how
does this application get added to the configuration.
So let's just copy and paste this. We
can also have launch, I guess it doesn't
really matter.
It's gonna do the authentication dance to make
sure that we have access to this application
and now we can browse to it via
nginx.t.rokode.sh.
Now, something I haven't shown yet is what
happens if we do that at a private
tab? Well, what should happen is we get
the Teleport login.
We cannot use that name. We cannot go
through the application proxy service without being an
authenticated Teleport user.
Very cool.
Okay. The last part of this exercise as
well. Okay.
Sorry. The second last part
is Okay. We don't want the
public to have access
to this. So you can see here we
go through the Teleport service,
but let's go through the node IP.
There's the node IP. Yeah. We did open
that. And I can close this one.
And we don't want this available. Anyone has
it, the node IP can browse their application.
We're considering it relatively sensitive at this point
in time, so we don't want that to
work.
Okay. So we can modify our default engine
next thing here.
What we can say is listen
One. And I can just remove that. Right?
Who's actually doing IPv six anyway?
But now we can say lesson on local
was only
hopefully oh, top 400 x. Hopefully, I haven't
broken this.
Looks alright.
And if we do a curl localhost
eighty eighty,
we get a response.
If we pop over to here, the IP
address one,
we have lost it. Right? This NGINX application
is no longer publicly available.
And the last part of this exercise is,
well, is it available via the Teleport proxy?
And the answer is yes.
Perfect.
So that is how you take
a application running within your infrastructure.
You bind it to a private interface. You
just remove it from the Internet and expose
it through Teleport using
the really great
application authentication
proxy.
Russell,
I just tried that. Cool. I hope it
worked.
All right, exercise seven. So
let's do this. So definitely let's try and
take, you know, NGINX is great, but you
know, one of the most
common use cases I have to use this
specifically, and I'm assuming everyone is the same
is that Grafana
is something that usually has access to a
lot of monitoring and observability data.
We run it on public interfaces because it's
easy, but at the same time, we
probably wanna restrict access to it depending on
what we have there. So we
are going to install Docker on the server
and then pull the image and run it.
And we're gonna use Docker
port publishing that is bound to
the private IPv4
or the local host address.
And then we'll add this to Teleport.
And the one twist we're doing with this
one is just to show off some more
application features is that we can modify that
DNS name that has been generated for us
whenever we add the application.
But here I'm doing gnt.
Rockode. Sh or g. T. Rockode. Sh.
Now, whenever I need to install Docker, I
go to get. Docker.io
and I grab this.
So we take off the dash o and
just paper straight to bash.
I think we just need to give this
thirty seconds and then I'll be able to
pull the Grafana image.
We look at the solution
for the last one.
There we go. For the solution, we pretty
much did exactly the last we just announced
install engine x. We added engine x with
the URI here, although I was actually using
port 80, not important.
And then we listen on the private IPv4.
Or you oh, actually, I used one two
seven, but I could have used the private
IPv.
And then we did confirm that it still
works. Perfect.
We're still waiting on Docker just now. Won't
be too long.
Oh, and my ferret is awake.
Okay. Cool. We have Docker. So let's do
Docker
container
run
dash r m dash background
dash
publish port.
And I'm gonna be very specific here.
And when we use the port syntax with
the IP address, it's just telling the interface
to listen on.
We also want to run,
is it just called Grafana?
Or
is it Grafana Grafana?
Yeah. I think it's Grafana Grafana.
I could've looked at the solution, but I'm
trying not to. Yeah. There we go. Grafana
Grafana
Grafana. Grafana, Grafana,
Grafana.
I think it's just that. Let's see.
So what we're gonna do is we'll pop
over
to the
oh, I closed it.
Grab the IP address again
On port three thousand.
And nothing works. Good.
If we do a container l s, we
should hopefully see a happy container. We do
it up for nineteen seconds.
Compassionate
swaddles.
Cool. I'll take it.
If we do a curl
on local host,
let me see if we actually get a
response. So Grafana is running in a container
with a very specific
published port to the local interface
that is not available to the external world,
but we want people that we have trust
with, that are authenticated with Teleport to have
access to this application.
So we're gonna continue as we did with
NGINX and we're gonna go into our application
config.
We're gonna add a new app,
call this Grafana,
the URI
local host
3,000.
Now what we said well, in fact, let's
just get it running first and then we'll
change it.
Restart Teleport.
So what should happen now
is I should be able to because I
know how the naming structure works. It's pressed
to
httpsgrafana.t.rockode.sh.
And after a little bit of an authentication
dance, we should get the login page for
Grafana.
Looks good.
Well, the exercise said, look, we don't want
it available on grafana.t.rawkode.sh.
Perhaps people know to check for Grafana on
sub domains, or we just have another reason
for one not available elsewhere. So how do
we control this DNS?
Well, let's go back to my favorite page
and the documentation,
reference,
no,
setup reference,
contact fail. We can pop down to the
app service,
and we'll see that we actually have
all of the fields that we are not
using being
commented on to tell us what to do.
We can tell it to escape and secure
certificates if we want. If we're running something
that has self signed certificates on our server,
which is quite common for private stuff, especially
if it can't pass any of the ACME
certificate
requests or
process.
We can modify the public address, which we
are going to do.
Labels and commands, we can obviously play with
later, and there's some redirect stuff that we
can talk about for applications such as, like,
WordPress that do a whole bunch of redirecting
based on whether you authenticate to trying to
get to the admin portal,
some of the assets or
doing internal redirects to, you can handle all
of that.
But right now, all we want to do
is
modify our Teleport. Yaml,
change the public address
to g.t.Rawkode.sh.
Restart Teleport.
Pop over here. We'll change this g
to a t.
There we go. Oh,
again.
There we go.
I think it's admin admin. Right?
Yeah. New password.
I don't know if you can figure that.
It worked.
Okay. Let's pop open a solution, make sure
we haven't missed anything.
So I did install Docker with
Kernel Bash.
My run command was pretty identical to that,
which is good.
And we use the public ADDR to make
sure
that we can control naming of our application.
Okay. We've got a couple more things to
do.
What if we want
semi public access?
This is an extremely contrived
scenario
that I'm gonna reuse on gitx and
admin
page, but
you can use Teleport
and, you know, your web server to restrict
access. You know, we got with Apache, we
have HD access. Within the next, we can
add location blocks where we can just say,
actually, you don't have access to this from
certain IPs or without certain headers authentication,
etcetera. So we're gonna try and set that
up. It won't take us too long, but
our secret application is that we'll we need
NGINX installed first.
Oh, fat.
I see.
We're gonna do this one on the worker
node this time. Okay.
I I haven't mentioned it in the exercise,
but I'm pretty sure I meant to. So
I will update that. And I'm sure the
solution has a quirk that I want to
cover. So we're gonna do it this way.
Okay. So let's jump over here. We're on
our
worker. We don't have NGINX. So I'm going
to do
I have to install NGINX.
The next part of this is that we
want to set up our secret admin page,
which I'm just going to create an HTML
file in the web root.
We're waiting for that 1% again, aren't we?
I wonder what it's doing. I think of
the man pages for engineering, if that's what's
actually
installing it.
Although I must also say these are really
small nodes.
These are the nano core ones. So I'm
actually not throwing too much power at this,
which is probably why it's taking a little
bit longer.
Alright. There we go. So here is my
admin page. With that, let's go to our
www HTML,
Cat admin.
There we go. Wonderful stuff.
Restart.
If it doesn't start automatically,
for sure.
Okay.
So let's confirm
w one
Rawkode.
H.
There's no yep. There we go. There's a
page. And we can just browse to admin.HTML
and we get our really secure
admin page.
This is not what we want.
Okay. Where's my
to do list? So we want to modify
the NGINX virtual host or site, whatever you
wanna call to block non local traffic to
the admin page.
Okay. Let's do that.
Enabled.
Here's our default.
Pop down here.
And we can do
location
admin dot HTML.
Rather than look at my solution, I'm going
to
Google it.
Well, yeah, there's my search from there. There
we go.
Because this this is this is how you
find the answers to stuff. Mean, you don't
remember off the top of your head.
We go to Google.
And I'm pretty sure it's just allow
and then the
cider.
Hello.
Let's just try.
That's the only one I clicked on. Alright.
Okay.
Hello.
+1 27.
Not 1.
Yeah. I think that's it.
Restart
it.
Not yelling at me.
Yeah. Okay.
Let's have a look.
It didn't work. Alright. We're looking at my
solution.
I forgot that denial.
Is this middleware?
Alright.
So then
nginx place enabled
default
local.
Restart.
Alright. So let's
there. Perfect.
So we've blocked
admin.HTML.
We still have access to the homepage.
Now we're doing this for a very superficial.
We expect the request to come from the
local machine.
And that works all right in this scenario.
Russell has lost access to his admin page.
We're
gonna fix it.
So,
yeah, this works really well.
Having that denied there,
it's just a really simple way of protecting
access to certain components.
Wirecards work really well for NGINX and the
patches where you can really make this work,
where you have something that as public,
90% of it, maybe 50% of it. But
there are components of it. You're like, gosh,
I really don't want that exposed. Maybe there
is legacy application. You don't want to extract
it out to a new thing yet. Like
whatever your scenarios are,
this works really well. And you can do
this through anything that has layer seven visibility.
So even if this was in Kubernetes, you
know, rather than like an NGINX, then I
you could build this up to
you know, Selim network policy or whatever. So
lots of different ways you can do this,
but now what we want to do is
regain access
to the service.
So,
hello, welcome. Thank you for joining the workshop
today.
Okay. So now we need access back.
Now,
I'm gonna show you how it doesn't work
first.
And that you'd be very tempted to come
into this
and add our app service.
Enabled,
true.
And you'd say we we have an app
that we want to expose through the Teleport
cluster, which has a name of admin
with a URI
of HTTPS.
Oh no, sorry.
HTTP
localhost.
Then change the ports that this session is
running on port 80 and saving that. Now,
of course I even attempted this the first
time. However, there's a bit of a situation
and that if we do a system control,
we start Teleport.
Teleport
is that it crashes and we get some
errors there.
But it turns out that we can't
expose applications in this way,
with this node configuration.
Teleport,
if it's not running the auth service and
the proxy service cannot run the application service
on the node, you actually have to go
a slightly different route, which is to use
the teleport
app start
command,
like so.
So this runs
application proxy that works in just this mode
and allows you to export your applications and
you would run one of these for each
of your applications you want to do. I'm
not gonna do it just now and create
a unit fail and all that. We just
kinda wanna get this working,
but we could do an app start and
we know our token is Rawkode workshop.
And we know that our auth server
is t.rawkode.sh.
And now we just need to name, which
is admin and a URI,
which is http
localhost.
What did I get wrong?
Maybe I don't need the 38.
Maybe I do. Oh, no. I've I've broken
Teleport.
Which need we need for the tunnel.
Teleport happy. Teleport is happy. Okay. So let's
come back to this.
Maybe that's.
You're very very We're look at the solution
again, aren't you?
Oh, then
they can't have my tunnel.
It's my teleport running.
Yeah.
Alright. Let's just look.
I did document this here that when running
Teleport process as an application proxy,
it's much easier to create a unit file,
which I would encourage you to do.
The issue for the
thing that I mentioned is here.
So at the start has exit and
someone from Teleport has
turned in to say that this doesn't work
and you need to run proxy service and
app service in separate processes,
which is fine.
You can see that they have off service
null here.
So now we just do a little
bit of tidying up.
I pop over here, here's my start command.
Did I get something wrong?
Oh yeah, four forty three, not 38.
Because we have a TLS
version
of our thingy running.
Okay. That worked better. Trying to change the
command. Nope.
Great thing about copy and paste. Okay. So
that was the exact same command.
I just got the port wrong.
So it's Teleport app start. We give the
application a name, the URI to find it,
token, and the off server. That's now running
as quite happy.
So we're gonna pop over
here.
You can see our Grafana and there we
have our admin
at launch.
Medication dance.
Oh, actually, I found this earlier. It doesn't
work it out.
Let's try one more time.
Admin.p.Rawkode.
Oh, no. It worked. Okay. I have trouble
with the admin prefix. It wasn't resolving. And
I could actually like, when I run deg
admin.t.rawkode.c,
it just wouldn't resolve at all, but only
admin dot that appears that was just a
temporary thing. So now we have our application
here.
And if we go to admin.HTML,
we have forbidden.
That wasn't expected. Let me make sure I
got my rule correct.
I'm just gonna open a new thing.
Mhmm. Internet.
It's enabled.
Default.
So
what's my
I just wanna make sure
that
dot 0 dot zero. We could be coming
across the network.
I'm gonna do this.
I'm gonna restart my application.
No.
I wanted to restart engine x.
That's the wrong course.
Restart
engine.
And
there's a really good way to debug this
if it doesn't work.
There is a.
Re
log.
Think that's right.
No.
Relate log.
Yes.
Internet rewrite
log
on.
There
we go.
If we can now come to here
monitor our error log,
we should see if we still get a
deny why we got the deny.
So let's force the deny through
w one.
Yeah. This is me going to the node
directly.
That should be from my public IP address.
We look here.
Our client 82
has been denied, which is what we expect.
And
if
we come through admin. T,
we're still being denied.
Ah, okay.
So it's coming over the IPv6
address.
We can fix that.
So let's just make one final modification
here.
We're actually going to allow
one
tail.
There we go.
Now coming through the Teleport
authenticated
proxy,
we have access to our admin page, but
the public world does not. I will update
the workshop with me just so that the
correct thing is there, and this already is.
No. Okay. Cool. And so I can get
that fixed. But that's a really cool application
and you'll see it for the Teleport application
I really love that semi private public thing,
just leveraging NGINX,
Apache, anything like that to block the things
that we don't want people to have access
to.
We're just gonna take a look at one
more thing and then we'll finish up today's
workshop, which is well, actually,
what if I need local access and I
don't wanna have to go through the Teleport
system? Can I use T control to build
to do this?
And the answer is yes.
So we can do a TCTL
auth
And
that was my old name from workshop one.
We're gonna authenticate against
ECCL
off
server. There we go.
I
think I got that wrong in the last
workshop too.
Oh, no. I'm using the wrong command, aren't
I?
Nope. I have no idea what I'm doing.
T s h
off.
Why can I not remember anything?
Log in. There we go.
Proxy.
Okay.
Dot s h. It's gonna ask me for
my username and my password. Sweet.
Grab that from here.
Rawkode Teleport.
Copy.
My OTP.
Back in oh,
think I one there. I'm gonna have to
grab it from this browser.
There we go.
And I probably copied the wrong password, that
thing, because I have issued the wrong one.
So
password.
OTP.
Haven't seen that before.
I am
I could delete all of that.
I'll try that one more time.
Do I need the whole thing?
I don't think you do. I think it
just wants the domain name.
Yeah.
Because I already add that.
Let's try again.
It won't let me down.
Password.
OTP.
Just in case we're going to add
and secure.
Because I I'm I'm not sure.
The joy of doing things live.
Address.
Okay.
We are running Teleport eight.
I wonder
if because my client is older.
Yeah. There's eight zero zero there. We'll try
this. If this doesn't work,
I'll
pretend to go through the process of what
should work. Again, we shouldn't need unsecure because
we're we're raising less encryption certificates here. Our
proxy is t dot Rawkode dot s h.
Let's grab this password again.
Copy.
Second to FE.
Paste.
Alright. We are now authenticated
with our
our Teleport cluster.
Now we can run ectl
apps ls,
and we can see each of our applications.
We take a look at that app sub
command.
No, that's not very one.
Maybe it's TSH app.
Yep. There we go. I never remember when
you're supposed to use TSH and T control.
But we can do an apps login.
We will log in to our let's look
at what does the thing tell me to
do?
Our seeker application first. Okay. So that's called
admin.
And you will see that what
TSH is now doing is pulling down this
certificate
information that we need to do the
the TLS handshake with the application, with the
Teleport Proxy Service to be able to browse
to that application.
And now if we copy and paste the
curl,
we should
be able to hit admin.
HTML,
and we get the admin page back.
The last thing we want to do is
just take a look at our dumper.
So that can just be our TSH apps
login again,
dumper,
and we're just gonna get the same information
back. Now you can imagine if this was
an API that you're working on a Kubernetes
cluster, you wanna be able to write tests
or something like that. This is a really
good way to get that configured.
And we can see all the same information
that we need to.
And we can also do an apps logo
dumper. It's just gonna remove our
certificates, our keys, and etcetera, and clean up
things up so we don't we no longer
have access
to it.
So Russell is asking,
is there a CLI command to check the
version of the client server? Like, you can
definitely do it to get the version and
check the client version. I wouldn't think there
is any way to get the server version
other than a TCL status,
which is gonna give you the version here.
But that would be great if I could
just run like a, I guess because you
can be authentic to against multiple clusters.
Yeah.
Definitely feedback for the Teleport team. It would
be nice to get a warning to see
in the client and server different versions before
getting really,
really bizarre messages that don't make a lot
of sense. Like, hey, failed to authenticate with
a handshake and a fail. Like, that doesn't
tell me anything.
It was just sheer chance that I remember
the versions were different. So,
yeah, room for improvement there.
But that's it. Thank you. Well, let me
pop back over.
I know. I had a repo.
But, yeah.
Hopefully you enjoy
this workshop and we've got another one coming
on Kubernetes.
Stay tuned for that.
Check it out. Run through it in your
own pace. I will get the typos and
random things that were messy today, especially the
IPv6
on the deny block for NGINX fixed.
No one else has to run into that.
I hope you found that enjoyable. Teleport is
a wonderful application.
App access has so many different potentials that
make it just wonderful for exposing things like
Grafana,
backend portals, admin portals, etcetera, from your infrastructure
in a secure fashion.
So thanks for joining me today. I hope
you have a good one, and I will
see you all soon. Thanks a lot. Bye.